springtime means easter brunch is on the
horizon and the veranda at four seasons
hotel las vegas has something special
for the entire family and here tell us
more is chef william ledesma welcome
william how are you thank you so much
for having me
we great thank you so much it's great to
have you here so kind of give us a
bird's-eye overview of what we expect at
brunch uh first of all uh i want to
invite everybody you know to join us
after two years of having a little hard
time to come and join us again to or
something it's been a tradition in vegas
or sunday easter brunch so
please you know whoever have it there's
no restrictions this year
normal no restrictions we we we are all
in uh we have a few
surprises for all you know all our
customers especially uh we're gonna have
a easter bunny going around we have some
live music wait the easter bunny yes the
easter bunny's going to be there
because this is that this is the one
easter bunny this is this is a family
affair this is a brunch for the entire
family you guys yes buddy we also
have some stuff for those we have uh
some craft cocktails especially for that
for that for the day so
and uh we are promoting some uh stations
live station that we're gonna showcase
that day okay that's exactly what we're
gonna prepare today what are you gonna
make for us here today yep so
competition's going on today so we're
going to have a few uh two stations uh
going on the day so one of them is going
to be our bruschetta an avocado bar so
which is ready to go you know we we're
going to be able to make your uh
whatever you decide that they
feel like avocado crab tomatoes you're
putting there on top of the toast making
right for us
choices of toast and juice of toppings
and one of the uh the highlights so that
they will be a
martini station so we are taking our
playing of uh shimon grits today
so we have a little bit of a
creamy polenta we're going to place it
right here's your spin on the shrimp and
grits pretty much that's that's how
that's how we come out with this dish a
little bit of creamy polenta now as
you're making this we are recommending
that people because reservations you
said before we started the show are
available but you need to make
reservations now because this will book
up so we we can we invite you to make
reservations to 632 5000 that will be
the number to call to make our
reservation that needs to be now so
three o'clock in the afternoon yes
sunday april 17th easter sunday this is
delicious nine two three sir nine to
three so we have a little bit of crab
salad with roasted corn a little bit of
cilantro and uh dressing
and we're gonna topping it with uh uh
perfect perfect egg you need an egg on
easter sunday of course so we took it
with up okay you have a lot of different
food options there on easter sunday for
brunch what's the first thing people
should get when they get there because
they're gonna show up uh they're gonna
have an appetite they're gonna wanna eat
what are we going to go for if it's nine
o'clock 10 o'clock we'll say three
doughnuts we have a session with fresh
sweet donuts all right
but yeah i mean i will i will go for the
steak we have we have a grill grill
grill steaks and meats
we're gonna wrap every single what is
this here so we're gonna finish or or uh
or bending we don't we need a sauce
right so we we have a like a little
cajun cream okay make with a little bit
of lobster bisque
oh and
that black is fantastic and a little bit
of lemon oil just to finish this is the
veranda at four seasons for the for
sunday easter brushes
oh chef thank you so much so i'm
thanking you because i'm gonna eat this
when we go to break
and here we are thank you my friend and
awesome too give me the give me the uh
that plate over there too they show them
the shot the shot over here here we go
beautiful thank you which one can you
eat one of these would you recommend you
one i would recommend it to the right
hand okay let's try this here
please thank you so much
four seasons hotel easter bunch go check
it out las vegas now this is good we'll
be right back